[Musique]
le 2 juillet un homme au volant d'un
camion gris s'approche de rideau hall à
ottawa
il s'appelle khayarine un militaire
réserviste du manitoba et il est venu
pour confronter le premier ministre
nomme armé a été arrêté après avoir
foncé son véhicule dans l'enceinte de
sécurité à rideau hall sur les médias
sociaux de corinne on souligne la
présence de quelques messages codés
notamment un lapin blanc et la lettre qu
il s'agit d'une référence à un mouvement
no milk yoann
ce n'est pas la première fois que ce
groupe fait les manchettes et plusieurs
s'interroge sur son influence
potentiellement dangereuses
aux etats unis les adeptes de cloyne
hommes sont de plus en plus présents
lors de rassemblements publics et
certains poussent leur allégeance à
l'extrême à seattle en 2019
un homme accusé d'avoir tué son frère
avec une épée y aurait été inspiré par
canal au texas cette année une adepte de
la théorie a foncé sur deux étrangers
qu'elle aurait soupçonné de pédophilie
est cet homme qui aurait tué un parrain
de la mafia dit avoir été motivé par le
mouvement
ce genre de passage à l'acte a fait
réagir le fpr qui considère qu à nantes
comme une menace de terrorisme national
tu as mal il devenu un amalgame complexe
de différentes théories du complot dans
ce monde parallèle des célébrités comme
tom hanks et oprah winfrey y seraient
des pédophiles et lady gaga serait
cannibales et compagnie de meuble ferait
de la traite de personnes
hélas 5j serait conçu pour nous rendre
malade le canada n'est pas épargné les
adeptes de qu on en dise y prétendent
entre autre que justin trudeau serait
entouré de pédophile et que ce petit
café à baie-saint-paul serait lié au
trafic d'enfants des accusations
démenties ou carrément sens lors de la
route et quand même d'hystériser le
débat public ait rien de mieux que de
nous alerter sur le prétendu complot it
in east 7 à nice et notamment et le
criminel son érosion de la croyance en
l'autorité du gouvernement ni raison
dans la croyance de l'importance de la
science c'est tout des choses qui
auraient des impacts négatifs pour notre
démocratie
mais ce mouvement qui sème la méfiance
envers nos institutions prend de
l'ampleur à travers le monde kiwan ans
est aussi présent ici sur la toile et
dans la rue incursion dans l'univers des
conspirations
[Musique]
kiwan on a vu le jour dans les bas-fonds
de l'internet
c'est là qu'un internaute surnommé cube
qui prétend être un haut placé de
l'administration trump partage des
messages codés les ku drop
depuis 2007 près de 5000 messages ont
été relayées et le mouvement qu'on
maintenant des millions d'adeptes
tu as lancé une théorie que le monde est
contrôlé par un cabale d'élite
sataniques et le président sont prêtés
il eut en 2016 pour faire guerre avec le
type state le dip state où l'état
profond une fraternité secrète qui
contrôlerait le monde
marc-andré argentino est un des premiers
universitaire à jeter un regard critique
sur ce phénomène
quand j'ai tombé sur qui honore c'était
quelque chose de nouveau pour moi dont
je commence à creuser sur le web et j'ai
trouvé des vidéos de la propagande du
contenu et j'ai un peu tombé dans dans
le trou j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
dans les coins sombres d'internet pour
essayer de comprendre le mouvement à
plusieurs reprises je me suis dit que
c'était carrément fou je ne réalisais
pas à quel point le mouvement était
important
la journaliste américaine adrian la
france a passé un an à traquer
l'évolution du gro upe fondamentalement
tuyau est un mouvement pro trompe il y a
un groupe grandissant de personnes qui
sont prêtes à rejeter la vérité pour
appuyer trop tu n'es plus que dans les
coins sombres d'internet
le président est fait référence dans ses
tweets
cette vision du monde va continuer à
exister que 30 gagne ou non certains
candidats républicains affichent
ouvertement leur affinité pour que yoann
oui la plus connue margerie taylor green
va presque assurément gagné sa place au
congrès il n'est pas la seule des
candidats voient ce qui fonctionne pour
30 et copie sa stratégie ce poids
politique vient de la ferveur parfois
religieuse des adeptes de cloyne
il voue à trump comme un messie
ça ressemble vraiment à une nouvelle
religion qui est l'archétype du croyant
de kuoni scanner pense que n'importe qui
est susceptible à ça et on voit que
c'est pô juste du mont kibo et du ski on
voit des médecins des avocats des
politiciens des chercheurs en convois du
monde qui doivent qui sont intelligents
mais il tombe quand même en stop
sur twitter les adeptes de qu annonce
affichait fièrement et ouvertement parmi
les croyants des maires des grands mères
des militaires et les enseignants pour
tous et tous pour une autre vidéo
produite ici même au québec montre des
fans qui récite la devise du mouvement
c'est difficile pour quelqu'un de
d'évoluer dans un monde où tout est en
en mouvance de d'adhérents mouvement qui
dit regarde nous on sait exactement
qu'est ce qui se passe ce virus là il
n'existe pas ça fait tout partie d'un
plan satanique
c'est les réponses qui sont passés des
fiefs de l'émission les décrypteurs suit
ce phénomène depuis le début quelqu'un
qui par exemple pendant la pandémie de
table 19 s'est dit bon les masques ça
m'intéresse pas trop je pense qu'il ya
peut-être en guise souvent achetés les
masques si dangereux pour la santé
tonton du contenu qui ont un homme
commence à s'intéresser à ce mouvement
là et puis le bain et c'est pas juste
les masques c'est les vaccins qui sont
dangereux
c'est le gouvernement qui essaie
d'instaurer une dictature mondiale c'est
là on rentre dans le trafic d'enfants et
gt va donc ça passe vraiment rapidement
du cac à l'enfant
en fait c'est le grand paradoxe est tout
petit il faut se méfier des sources
il faut se méfier de ce qu'on vous dire
avec claude on est face à une source qui
est totalement anonyme qui de toute
évidence manipule des millions de gens
et ces gens qui sont manipulés pense que
la manipulation est ailleurs en fait et
ça c'est absolument dément depuis des de
la pandémie la croissance de keenan est
très importante
donc si on regarde depuis les six
derniers mois
au total si on opte en augmenté de 2
points 3 8 millions de membres dans les
groupes et les pages facebook
le québec est un endroit dans le monde
avec une des plus importantes
concentrations de la dette
c'est pas que yoann and pour toi tu vois
un appel très doucement personne qui est
un petit peu proche de donald rheault
[Applaudissements]
que lors des manifestations contre les
mesures sanitaires que les fans
québécois de qu anna se sont rassemblés
publiquement pour la première fois qu'on
a vu une augmentation de presque 300 %
dans les membres au québec et c'est
vraiment lié au mouvement anti masque au
québec
ce mouvement de contestation et surtout
mené par un petit groupe d'influenceurs
qui ont su apprivoiser la grogne
populaire permanent chinois ne s'est pas
limitée qu'aux états unis
les patineurs par tout le monde allez
dans la description pour vous abonner à
la page kiwan français qui nous aide à
comprendre les dessous de cette
opération anti réseaux pédocriminels
partir cette année le plus populaire des
influenceurs québécois se nomme alexis
cossette trudel il a name la chaîne
youtube radio québec fondée en 2017
ses premières vidéos qui n'attirait
alors que quelques milliers de
visionnement s'attaquer notamment à la
diversité et à l'immigration
si je me mets à parler de cul ouais nan
je rejoins énormément de monde parce que
les gens de toutes sortes d'horizon
conspirationnistes se sont greffés au
mouvement donc en tant qu'un français
soit greffé au mouvement qui ont dans le
ca donne instantanément accès à un
auditoire beaucoup plus large
je suis au maximum d'amis sur facebook
malheureusement vous pouvez suivre
on voit que alex que cette rude elle a
quand même un effort important et c'est
pas juste au québec ces vidéos sont
traduits en espagnol en italien et on y
trouve en europe
parlez moi de la percée de cuba en
france on a vu apparaître ce thème qu
elle donne vraiment au cours de cette
année avec d'abord par radio québec et
la chaîne d'alexis cossette trudel on
disait que on était en dictature puis
petit à petit on a vu des figures de la
composent sphère francophone suisses
belges français arrivé très
explicitement sur ce thème là
devenu un soleil très spécial ce qui
inquiète les observateurs du phénomène
ces calexico cette rude elle encourage
son public a ragé s'est posé des gestes
d'éventuellement de rupture d'avec cette
ces tyrannies c'est pas quelqu'un qui
est passé fit pas vraiment d'un acte de
nos côtés conflit il veut vraiment
mobilisé sa bosse on est dans une crise
sanitaire même facturé de toutes pièces
[Applaudissements]
cité des métiers
bon sens et sans oublier calcul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le québec est un des endroits où le
mouvement anti masquer les plus forts
qu'on est dans le plus gros qu au bout
de notre vie mais cet automne la
patience du gouvernement commence à
s'effriter
au québec c'est important de pouvoir
exprimer son désaccord avec le
gouvernement
jusqu à tinqueux sa nuit sport à la
santé publique
plusieurs de ceux qui croient que la
coved et exagérée qui s'inspire de dans
notre dos
tu as entre temps que la pandémie a été
manufacturés pour empêcher la réélection
du président américain
l'élection des non le virus gagner par
tous les moyens nécessaires protégé
alors on sait qui on est à la fin de la
pandémie corps humain un homme de sainte
brigitte de laval a été arrêté pour
avoir proféré des menaces sur les
réseaux sociaux à l'endroit du premier
ministre françois legault et du docteur
horacio arruda chez ceux qui croient
très fort à ce genre de complot le
sentiment de révolte peut se traduire en
colère ou même en menace on peut pas
écrire n'importe quoi dans les milieux
sociaux
les experts en matière de radicalisation
nous disent que les influenceurs entre
ce masque galvanise cette colère alexis
quoi cette rude elle a accepté de venir
nous parler de cul à nantes
il insiste que ce mouvement n'est pas du
tout dangereux jeugny exactement où il
est bien 92 à 100 % des gens qui
adhèrent au mouvement qu à nous devons
dire qu'il n'ya pas de mouvement qui a
pas de violence que c'est un mouvement
pacifique exactement comme ce que nous
on faisait rage au québec mais pourtant
à les efforts sur agout de cesser la
violence comme on dit en anglais c'est
bon ouvert on peut frapper dessus comme
on veut on peut frapper dessus comme on
veut ouais ouais ça c'était peut-être au
début de la pandémie il ajouté ouais les
gens étaient fâchés on se rend compte
que la roue de man ça c'est une chose ou
deux mains sur les chiffres démentent
annabelle à la violence mais sinon c'est
un appel à la violence je les dis depuis
le début à écouter et vous écouter et
vous devez encore une fois remettre ce
globe offres sur internet faisaient non
le goal de nous invente des chiffres sur
les quais vides
ceci est une liste de menaces qui ont
été proférées à l'égard de legault je
lui souhaite une balle perdue de legault
tu vas voir de voir quadruples été garde
du corps
bref on a fait l'analyse de ces
commentaires là on à 1,14 ici neuf sont
des fans de votre agent nommément que
votre logo comme image de profil comme
on peut
je dire valider ce à dire que c'est des
gens qui sont réellement avec nous alors
que la stratégie des autorités sans
toujours été de d'utiliser des agents
provocateurs pour détourner un mouvement
s'effectue dans votre écran ça c'est que
ce sont tous des imposteurs ce sont des
agents provocateurs
prenez aucune responsabilité pour ce
genre de discours tient évidemment nom
de mes vidéos qui ont été vue un million
de fois vous comprenez je peux pas être
responsable d action de 1 million de
personnes la rhétorique est beaucoup
plus acerbes du côté des médias
officiels que du côté de radio québec
vous avez aucune ambition politique j'ai
aucune émission connaissait mon horizon
moi c'était comme un an deux ans de
travaux se faire élire
l'anc est dur à mettre en course et que
la haute administration obama est
coupable d'espionnage et d'un watergate
à la puissance 10 que les journalistes
ici thèse donc aux abonnés à quoi
s'ajoutent des arrestations
ils vont être accusés de trahison c'est
ce que tu dis est ce que toutes les
institutions sont corrompues mais c'est
que sept frères
je ne sais pas si je dirais que toutes
les institutions sont corrompues d'une
partie où une partie des instances une
grosse partie des institutions qui sont
corrompus et de sa palette non si je
dirais pas pédo satanistes je veux dire
que on peut faire chanter des
politiciens avec des histoires de
pédophilie le taux de chômage
pratiquement à 100%
nous avons identifié de nombreuses
forces et de liens ténus et
d'interprétation douteuses dans les
vidéos d'alexis que c'est trudel le plus
de morts du tout peut jamais le deuxième
vague du virus
confronté à certaines de ses erreurs il
avoue se tromper à l'occasion vous est
que il ya aucun de pandémie dans
l'histoire qui a duré plus que deux à la
grèce la grippe espagnole n'est pas une
deuxième vague il ya une masse qui n'est
distanciation sociale la grippe
espagnole du windsor
il ya eu des masses qui avait déjà à peu
près seul exemple qu'on peut donner
mais si on attend on attend je vais
m'excuser j'ai aucun problème avec soit
des auditeurs le savent je me suis je me
suis souvent corrigé à l'écran seriez
pas de problème je sais
je vais souvent oui j'essaye le plus
possible que salue la gagne la prochaine
sur le fond de ces croyances par contre
alexis cosset trudel est immuable il
croit à free un service important
les gens nous ont dit après avoir écouté
les médias nous étions en détresse
psychologique
et quand on écouterait au québec ça nous
calme c'est seulement le message que
j'entende mais selon les témoignages que
nous avons recueillis ces théories créé
des clivages au sein de familles et de
groupes d'amis c'est un enjeu calexico 7
rue de lui même reconnu que moi ton
écoute des gens capables de la maison
pas parce que je pense que la sioniste
ça prend leur vie au complet ça prend
leurs liens ça prend leur métier
s'apprend leur vision du monde
ça prend tout nous avons parlé à une
dizaine de proches d'adeptes de cloyne
la plupart ont refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue à la caméra ou à visage
découvert par par d'exacerber les
relations déjà tendues avec leurs
proches
tout d'un coup ci c'est sale et je
voyais des familles éclatées une amitié
qui gisent brisés
c'est immense ce qui se passe est
immense il faut savoir se retenir cette
donne rien de dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord pour us ça leur donne du jus ça
leur donne du gaz
on dirait qu'ils sont comme assoiffés de
confrontation
les géants du web ont récemment commencé
à sévir pour réduire la portée de tuân
anh en octobre peu après notre
conversation avec alexis cossette trudel
facebook et youtube ont effacé des
centaines de pages liées au mouvement
dont celles de radio québec qui mène à
manhattan et d'histoire grâce aux
plateformes de réseaux sociaux à grand
déploiement
sinon ça aurait probablement juste
rester dedans soit dans ces forums
anonymes l'eau dans les cercles vraiment
hyper conspirationnistes cet automne en
réaction à toute l'attention médiatique
qu on en avait suggéré à ses adeptes de
se faire discret alexis que cette rude
elle avait alors retiré plusieurs de ses
vidéos sur le sujet on a l'impression
qu'il ya quelque chose qui s'en vient où
est ce qu'on va essayer de mal faire
paraître les gens qui ont tenu lyon qui
ont parlé tout en en face de quelqu'un
avec un chandail tuân anh va faire
quelque chose puis l'on voit si le blanc
mais tout le monde parce que
soudainement tous les médias
s'intéressent à cuban
[Applaudissements]
certains espèrent que cet engouement
pour les complots va se calmer après la
pandémie ou du moins après les élections
présidentielles aux états unis mais
d'autres croient que ce mouvement va
plutôt muté et persévérer ces choses
loft pour désormais partie du décor et
c'est quelque chose avec lequel la
classe politique les médias aussi
doivent composer qui venant n'existerait
pas si avait passé cynisme ambiant de
beaucoup de gens à voir les institutions
puis les incisions et même ensemble
partiellement responsable
on serait un peu naïf de penser que tout
le monde demain matin on voit bien à
lille au québec après cette crise là ça
a vraiment fait jamais quelque chose il
ya de plus en plus de personnes qui
embarque lot
[Applaudissements]
exemple
[Musique]